[Musique]
dans ce sens qu'a dit ce matin
universitaire de professeur pascal ça
fâche spécialisé dans les affaires
environnementales la géographie bonjour
merci d'être avec nous bonjour vous êtes
avec nous parce qu'elle s'attache au
monde deux ministres sont en martinique
pour se pencher sur cette invasion des
halles de sangatte il ya brigitte
girardin ministre d outre-mer et nicolas
hulot ministre de la transition
écologique parce que ça fâche des fonds
pour la recherche pour comprendre le
phénomène sans gaz des fonds pour mieux
ramasser les algues échouées
que nous reste-t-il encore à connaître
de ces algues mais en fait j'ai presque
envie de dire qu'il nous reste tout à
connaître parce qu'en fait ce sont pour
l'instant nous ne faisons que des
hypothèses nous émettons des hypothèses
en effet j'ai entendu d'éditos
l'éditorial de jean marc parti dans
lequel il dit que les algues sargasse
proviendrait ou en tout cas serait
fortement alimenté par les eaux chargées
de nutriments donc du fleuve amazone
c'est vrai ça cela semble plausible cela
semblerait en tout cas c'est l'hypothèse
qui est avancé aujourd'hui on sait très
bien que le fleuve congo ont fait de
même mais il semble aussi que les algues
qui comme un dirais-je stationnent si
j'ose dire qu'ils séjournent dans la mer
des sargasses pour pourrait aussi
potentiellement à la faveur de petites
modifications courantologie qu être
exportée vers les antilles ou en tout
cas vers l'afrique et après par le biais
de courant revenir vers les antilles
dont on ne sait pas tout du déplacement
de ces halles on ne sait pas encore tout
du déplacement de ces algues et la
recherche doivent véritablement mettre
l'accent sur la courantologie le
véritable fin le noeud du problème si
j'ose dire actuellement c'est la
courantologie et puis la prolifération
de ces algues escaut kudrow mort c'est
plus alors sur la prolifération des
algues on sait on connaît un peu la fin
on connaît pas un peu on connaît la
biologie donc de ces algues qui ont un
mode de reproduction totalement asexuée
c'est ce qu'on appelle la reproduction
végétative d'ailleurs il faudrait
véritablement que le grand public
comprenne que plus on fragmente les
algues sargasse et plus elles se
reproduisent
donc il ne faut surtout pas les
fragmenter lorsqu'on est lorsqu on les
ramasse ou lorsque l'on est en mer donc
on connaît si vous voulez la biologie
général de ces algues mais des études
sont en cours en trois par l'ird
institut de recherche pour le
développement pour un pur j'en veux dire
plus intime avec ces algues est
véritablement trouvé la manière de
éradiquée de les éradiquer surtout sans
que cela n'ait d'incidence sur le milieu
parce qu'il ne faut surtout pas que le
remède soit pire que le mal alors on va
faire de la politique fiction parce
qu'elle s'attachait ce qu'il ya moyen
par exemple détruire des molécules sur
ces aides pour qu'ils ne se reproduisent
on le fait pour le bluffer pour certain
nombre de choses pourquoi pas si c'est
alors il y arriviez un programme de
recherche qui vient d'être déposée et
qui lui propose de développer une enzyme
qui pourrait on va dire entre guillemets
stabiliser les algues sargasse c'est à
dire éviter qu'en se dégradant le libère
de l'hydrogène sulfuré de l'ammoniac
donc le programme étant et vient d'être
déposé donc une fois de plus le temps de
la recherche n'est pas le temps de
l'action donc il faudra encore sûrement
quelques bons mois avant qu'on ait des
résultats mais il ya une piste là qui
semble plausible de développer une
enzyme qui pourrait stabiliser les
algues éviter véritablement le problème
c'est le problème c'est que chaque fois
que l'homme intervient sur la nature de
la nature se venge tout auteur
d'ailleurs on le paye là bah oui là
c'est sûr que là vous avez raison et en
disant ça je crois que l'émission est
terminée vous avez tout dit en réalité
non mais une chose est sûre c'est que
les algues sargasse bon elle existait
par le passé puisque christophe colomb
déjà en parlait donc lors de ses
premiers voyages mais leur prolifération
est bien gardé ces mêmes salles que la
wii tout à fait d'elle
15e siècle xvième siècle on évoquait
déjà la présence d'algues sargasses et
je précise d'ailleurs que dans des
ouvrages anciens il est dit qu on les
utilisait pour amender les sols ou bien
elle était utilisée le problème c'est
qu'elle n'arrivait pas sur nos côtes en
quantité aussi aussi un port est ce que
le climat y est pour quelque chose
alors le climat ne n'est pas en il
semblerait que le climat ne soit pas
liée à la prolifération des algues mais
que le climat les modifications
climatiques que nous avons engendré
soient liés enfin engendre des
variations courantes aux logiques qui
elles mêmes font que nous recevons les
alpes parce qu'en fait elle séjourne il
faut bien comprendre que la mer des
sargasses c'est un site une portion de
l'océan atlantique dans portions dans
laquelle il y a des des milliers des
centaines de milliers de kilomètres
carrés d'algues sargasses mais celles ci
sont emprisonnés par des courants
circulaires qui les maintiennent sur
place et on observe depuis quelques
années des modifications pour
anthologique et on pense que ces
modifications courants théologiques sont
liées justement changement climatique je
crois qu'on savait tout avec linyola
nitoo ça n'a malheureusement ce sont des
phénomènes qui sont extrêmement
complexes et si on en connaît si vous
voulez les grands mécanique je rappelle
quand même qu avant de véritablement
comprendre ce qu'était el niño et la
niña
il s'est passé quasiment une vingtaine
d'années donc ce sont des mécanismes qui
sont d'une complexité extrême ans alors
il y a y at-il pas ce que ça fasse une
saison pour ces halles ou bien ce sera
tout cela n'est alors jusqu'à présent il
y avait une sorte de pseudo saison
c'était grossièrement on va dire du mois
de mars au mois de juillet août et puis
là on a observé cette année
malheureusement que un début de saison
bien précoce puisque ça va commencer
quasiment 1 décembre et le phénomène ne
semble pas près d'être de death terminer
pourquoi parce que lorsqu'on regarde des
images satellite al qui sont pris sur
l'océan atlantique
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya encore
d'importants rat d'eau d'algues qui sont
enfin qui se dirige vers nous donc on
pense que le phénomène va durer encore
quelques mois
et donc est ce qu'il y à une saison non
on ne peut pas dire qu'il y à une saison
des algues sargasse moi je croise très
honnêtement j'ai eu déjà l'occasion de
le dire il faut que nous nous habitions
à vivre avec les sargasses mais une fois
de plus je comprends parfaitement les
populations qui souffrent et qui ont
cette espèce d'odeurs sulfures
au quotidien c'est juste impossible à
vivre
alors vous l'aviez dit notamment lors de
l'assemblée générale du medef les
autorités touristiques avoir mal à la
tête
c'est sûr que l'impact des sargasses sur
l'activité économique et
particulièrement sur le tourisme très
honnêtement pour parler familièrement ça
va faire très mal au bout d'un moment
parce que le problème c'est que au
départ le bon cette information est
quand même relativement j'ai envie de
dire confiné n
elle n'a pas franchi beaucoup de
frontières et puis de ce chemin faisant
en plus avec l'arrivée des ministres
on commence à en parler beaucoup au
niveau national on commence à en parler
au niveau international vous noterez
d'ailleurs que les îles voisines en
parle très peu d'aidés des sargasses me
demande si la cdu code du tourisme
voilà leur économie étant basé sur
l'activité touristique donc il
communique très peu sur ceux là nous on
communique beaucoup et je crains
malheureusement que l'impact sur cette
activité soit majeur dans l'est dans les
mois à venir on va le précise il n'y a
pas que la martinique également barbade
mais pas seulement il ya la république
dominicaine crous les petites et les
grandes antilles aujourd'hui même les
côtes mexicaines de la floride
mais en fait le problème c'est pas un
problème si vous voulez qui est juste
régionales là on est vraiment dans un
problème qui est international c'est un
problème qui affecte tout le bassin
atlantique et c'est la raison pour
laquelle bon j'ai entendu dire tout à
l'heure qu'il qu'il fallait régler le
problème à l'échelle de la région oui
c'est vrai il faut le régler à l'échelle
de la caraïbe mais il faut surtout le
régime le régler à l'échelle du bassin
atlantique
parce que visiblement les les algues
proviennent ou proviendrait de la région
qui sont quand même bien éloignées des
nôtres et donc il faut que ce soit tous
les pays qui les bandes 800 km oui des
bandes de 800 kilomètres voire des
banques qui sont pour certains ont été
mesurés qui sont bien plus importants
des banques qui font jusqu'à 1200 km de
long quand on sait que la martinique les
70 km de long parce que ça fâche un
autre volet le recyclage de ces algues
que peut-on faire
il ya notre voisine de celle ci qui
tentent de refaire un engrais ne sait
pas encore si cet engrais serait si
profitable que cela pour pour
l'agriculture
qu'est ce qu'on préfère 2,6 alors tout
d'abord concernant langue grecque et qui
est produit à sainte lucie sait pas
qu'il ne soit pas profitable pour
l'agriculture c'est que la comédie âge
les normes européennes
ne sont pas les normes simplicien donc
dans les normes heureux les normes
européennes imposent qu'il y ait des
seuils précis en matière de chlordécone
en matière de métaux lourds et caetera
et la nomenclature ou la voilà la
nomenclature sainte lucienne ne respecte
pas les mêmes normes dans ces métaux
lourds sont présentes naturellement ou
bien c'est vraiment elle ce qui vient
des produits phytosanitaires
alors on retrouve des métaux lourds à
l'état naturel dans l'eau de mer mais ce
sont des traces est ce que les quantités
infinitésimales
et puis bien évidemment tout ce que
l'homme rejette dans l'océan puisque
l'océan malheureusement qu'on est un peu
un pin à poubelles
ben bien entendu ces algues fixe tous
ces métaux lourds que l'on retrouve dans
l'eau alors en dehors de ces deux c'est
au gré aussi dès qu'on peut peut-être
encore travailler pour améliorer rendre
aux normes européennes peut être que
pourrait-on faire de ces add on pourrait
par exemple en faire des sachets en
plastique alors il est possible de
transformer les algues sargasse en une
sorte de polymères sanya une sorte de
substance qui ressemble au plastique
pour faire donc des produits usuels les
produits de la vie courante donc des
pots à fleurs ou enfin toutes sortes de
détails pour contenir l'eau que nous
alors je ne sais pas si on peut faire
des bouteilles parce que pour pour pour
stocker de l'eau d'un il faut vraiment
un ce plastique spécialement en tout cas
pour faire au moins des petits objets de
la vie cultuelle qui ressemble à du
plastique par exemple si x fleur des
pois fleurs ça c'est faisable
il ya déjà eu des tests et ça marche
très bien et ça a été réalisée à partir
des algues sargasse récoltés en
martinique le problème c'est que les
entreprises qui peuvent faire cela
demande à ce que ces algues bleues un
leur soient livrés et deuxièmement
qu'elles soient dépourvus de sel est
dépourvu de sable c'est à dire qu'il
faudrait un une capacité énorme pour
transporter ces algues et deuxièmement
il faudrait les laver abondamment avant
de les livrer à l'entreprise qui
pourraient potentiellement les
transformer donc c'est à dire qu'il
faudrait mettre en place toute une
filière
si vous voulez donc ce qui serait bien
ça permettrait de créer de l'emploi je
pense
on peut on peut se permettre vu la
situation que nous connaissons soit
régulier le phare de produits et voilà
le véritable problème c'est que les
producteurs les producteurs disent nous
nous souhaitons que vous nous
fournissent y ait ces algues tout au
long de l'année et qu'il n'y ait pas de
rupture aller les chercher directement
sur cette frange de 1200 km au large du
brésil
alors autant aller les chercher sur
cette frange de 1200 km mais encore
faut-il disposer des moyens pour les
récupérer c'est la raison pour laquelle
dans un article j'avais j'avais proposé
donc de développer cette filière qui
consisterait à récolter les algues en
mer puisque on sait qu'il est possible
de les récolter en mer mais encore
faut-il enfin con qu'on voit qu'on le
veuille et puis qu'on mette les moyens
pour le faire
est ce qu'il ya des projets martinique
et autour du recyclage de ces salaires
alors je sais qu'un certain nombre de
professionnels que j'ai rencontrés lors
de la réunion du medef récemment ce sont
louis sont sont intéressés et maintenant
ils sont quand même relativement
interrogatif face au phénomène parce que
il eu l'heur leur inquiétude c'est de
savoir si ça va durer si ça dure il y a
potentiellement matière à travailler si
ça ne dure pas malheureusement c'est pas
rentable
l'universitaire parce qu elle se fâche
est avec nous dans son crédit cela très
bonne journée
merci merci